the porn man
um have you like there's so many
different inner workings within the no
jumper Universe between like uh just
politics or certain people don't [ __ ]
with it it just it seems like a lot
between the Flacco guy or there's like
you know there's just so many different
personalities
I see where you're going with it no bro
I got listen everybody got love for each
other there ain't no problem you know
what I wasn't even gonna say that I was
gonna ask you like is it is it is it is
like a more of a big family or does
everybody just kind of do their family
we all together even though we got to do
what we got to do separately that's what
makes us a team so
you know it's been all gravy trained
over there everybody yeah everybody
focused everybody's buckling down I
don't think Adam would have invested
into even having a new office the new
building looks crazy and I don't think
he would have put that together if
everybody was on Rocky terms or
everybody's just kind of doing their own
thing no it's about bringing ideas
together and how can we make this bigger
that's fair man you know what I'm saying
how can we make this bigger but you know
we ain't just trying to bring on those
suckers so everybody stop trying to DM
trying to hey man we gotta start and all
man come on man if it's gonna happen for
you let it happen organically also like
I feel like everything like you said
it's got to be organic It's gotta be man
if you came in for an interview and then
from there it was like damn and that's
documented yeah you know what I'm saying
[ __ ] don't know go watch it 100
you'll see for sure